This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. The podcast endless thread is a great show at a WBUR in Boston, but examines the blurred line between the online world and the real world. And their recent series is all about memes, those little bits of culture that are easily passed around the internet and are meant to convey a lot of information in a single glance. Memes are changing everything from our politics to our senses of humor to how we communicate online and in real life.
这里是《99%无形》（99% Invisible），我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。播客《无尽线索》（Endless Thread）是波士顿WBUR电台的一档优秀节目，它探讨了网络世界与现实世界之间模糊的界限。他们最近的系列节目全是关于“模因”（memes）的——那些在互联网上广为流传、旨在让人一眼就能获取大量信息的文化碎片。模因正在改变一切，从我们的政治、幽默感，到我们在网上和现实生活中的交流方式。
I was recently taken with an episode of this series that was totally in my wheelhouse as both a young comic book collector and a lover of effective logos. It's all about the Punisher Skull. Not to brag, but I had the very first Punisher Limited Series comics as a kid, and I love them. The Punisher is a character that really appeals to a 12 year old who has a chip on his shoulder and wishes he was a badass. But since his first appearance as a villain in Spider-Man, the Punisher Skull emblem has escaped the pages of the comics and is now being painted on police vehicles, adopted by
最近，这个系列中的一集深深吸引了我，因为它完全击中了我的兴趣点，我既是一位年轻的漫画书收藏家，也是一位高效标志的爱好者。这一集讲的是“惩罚者”（Punisher）的骷髅标志。不是我吹牛，我小时候就有第一套《惩罚者》限量版漫画，我非常喜欢。惩罚者这个角色真的很吸引那些心怀不满、渴望成为硬汉的12岁男孩。但自从他作为反派在《蜘蛛侠》中首次亮相以来，惩罚者的骷髅徽章已经走出了漫画书页，现在被喷涂在警车上，被
members of the military and dawned by white supremacists. Something the original creator of the character finds troubling, to say the least. Here is the story of the Punisher's symbol as a meme. Its origins, its use today, and whether it's creator, or marvel, or Disney for that matter, can take it back. This is Endless Thread, hosted by Amory Severson and Ben Brock Johnson. Some origin stories kick off with radioactive spider bites or alien planets. And some begin with good old fashioned bloodshed. If society won't punish, But guilty. He will.
军方成员采用，并被白人至上主义者佩戴。至少可以说，该角色的原创者对此感到不安。这就是惩罚者标志作为模因的故事。它的起源、它在今天的用途，以及它的创造者，或者漫威，甚至迪士尼，是否能把它收回。这是《无尽线索》，由阿莫里·塞弗森（Amory Severson）和本·布洛克·约翰逊（Ben Brock Johnson）主持。有些起源故事始于放射性蜘蛛咬伤或外星行星。而有些则始于老派的流血事件。如果社会不惩罚罪犯，他会。
He was a Vietnam vet, you know, an honorable soldier. And he had a family. I can't believe he. I'm old. His family was killed in crossfire in Amatya shootout in Central park. Get down, buddy, get down! Get down!
他曾是一名越战老兵，你知道的，一位光荣的士兵。他有一个家庭。我真不敢相信他。我老了。他的家人在中央公园的一场交火中被杀害。趴下，伙计，趴下！趴下！
Get down! And when the police weren't able to bring the criminals to justice, he went and took the law into his own hands. This is not vengeance. Revenge is not a valid motive. It's an emotional response. No, not vengeance. Punishment. You don't have to kill me, Ovinous. It was him or us! Call me... the Punisher.
趴下！当警察无法将罪犯绳之以法时，他便亲自采取了行动。这不是复仇。复仇不是一个正当的动机。这是一种情绪反应。不，不是复仇。是惩罚。你不需要杀我，奥维努斯（Ovinous）。不是他死就是我们亡！叫我……惩罚者。
Call me the Punisher. He was an intended to be a good guy, but he was intended to be a vigilante anti-hero who at least had his own code of justice and wouldn't cross a certain line, but was definitely considered an outlaw. This guy knows a lot about the Punisher because he invented him. I'm Jerry Conway, I'm a comic writer and TV writer.
叫我惩罚者。他本意并非要成为一个好人，但他被设定为一个义务警员式的反英雄，至少他有自己的正义准则，不会越过某条底线，但他绝对被视为一个亡命之徒。这个人对惩罚者了解很多，因为他创造了他。我是杰瑞·康威（Jerry Conway），我是一名漫画作家和电视编剧。
I'm the co-creator of the Punisher and various other characters that have appeared on TV and in movies. Including three Punisher films, which we heard some snippets from. Jerry was a professional comic book writer by the age of 16. He's in his late 60s now, with tough-d white hair. He has a nerdy laugh that he follows statements with, which is endearing. On the internet, he describes himself
我是惩罚者和其他出现在电视和电影中的角色的共同创作者。包括三部惩罚者电影，我们刚才听到了一些片段。杰瑞在16岁时就成为了一名职业漫画作家。他现在60多岁了，留着硬朗的白发。他说话后总会发出一种书呆子气的笑声，这很讨人喜欢。在互联网上，他形容自己
as a minor pop culture icon, and a modest and unassuming fellow well liked by those who don't know him. And Jerry is pretty modest, considering he's scripted classics like Marvel's The Amazing Spider-Man. It was actually in that series, back in 1974, that Jerry introduced the Punisher as a villain, an exceptionally violent and murderous one. He was a bad guy. Yeah, in the Marvel Universe, there is no such thing as a complete bad guy.
是一个小众流行文化偶像，一个谦逊、低调、被不了解他的人所喜爱的人。考虑到他曾为漫威的《神奇蜘蛛侠》等经典作品编写剧本，杰瑞确实很谦虚。事实上，正是该系列在1974年，杰瑞将惩罚者作为反派引入，一个极其暴力和嗜杀的反派。他是个坏人。是的，在漫威宇宙中，没有绝对的坏人。
You know, I mean, there are no mustache twirlers in the Marvel universe. The man who becomes the Punisher has a real name, Frank Castle, and like so many bad guys in comic books, Frank has a tragic backstory. The horrors of fighting in the Vietnam War, followed by the murder of his entire family, left Frank traumatized, a misguided tortured soul. Still, Jerry says over the years the character has made it very clear. What he does is wrong.
你知道，我的意思是，漫威宇宙里没有那种捻着胡子作恶的坏蛋。成为惩罚者的人有一个真实的名字，弗兰克·卡索（Frank Castle），像漫画书里的许多坏人一样，弗兰克有一个悲惨的背景故事。越南战争的恐怖，加上他全家被杀，让弗兰克受到了创伤，成了一个误入歧途、饱受折磨的灵魂。尽管如此，杰瑞说多年来这个角色已经表达得很清楚了。他所做的是错误的。
The way his enemies identify him, a huge terrifying white skull with four extra long fangs plastered across his extremely muscular chest. And it's this symbol we want to tell you more about, because even if you've never heard of the Punisher, I bet you've seen that skull emblem before. The one with the squinty eyes and the piano key like teeth. Maybe you've noticed it on t-shirts, hats, bumper stickers, matched up with pro-police thin blue line flags. You may have even spotted it on officers' uniforms, patrol cars, or permanently etched
他的敌人辨认他的方式，是一个巨大的、令人恐惧的白色骷髅，有着四颗超长的獠牙，印在他极其强壮的胸膛上。我们想告诉你更多关于这个标志的信息，因为即使你从未听说过惩罚者，我敢打赌你也见过那个骷髅徽章。就是那个眯着眼睛、牙齿像钢琴键一样的标志。也许你在T恤、帽子、保险杠贴纸上注意到过它，或者它与支持警察的“细蓝线”（thin blue line）旗帜搭配在一起。你甚至可能在警官的制服、巡逻车上看到过它，或者永久地刻在
on skin. It was a photo somebody at tattooed the Blue Lives Punisher logo, you know, the blue stripe variation on it on their arm and then above it they had tattooed I don't read and then below it Punisher comics I thought yep So we've been wondering how in the world did the mark of a fictional vigilante assassin who's not on society side and has a hit list a mile long, become a totem of mainstream law and order. And lately, almost a visual dog whistle for political factions in the US that seem increasingly
皮肤上。那是某人纹了“蓝命惩罚者”标志的照片，你知道，就是手臂上那个蓝色条纹的变体，然后在它上面纹了“我不读”，下面纹了“惩罚者漫画”，我想，是的。所以我们一直很好奇，一个虚构的、不站在社会一边、有一长串暗杀名单的义务警员的标志，到底是怎么变成主流法律和秩序的图腾的？最近，它几乎成了美国政治派系的一种视觉“狗哨”（dog whistle），这些派系似乎越来越
associated with violence. We're the baby, man! Where the hell the f*** you go? Just throw it up for all of you! I know what you're doing! Call me, Amary Severson. Call me, Ben Brock Johnson. From the WBUR Podcast Universe, we bring you Endless Thread. Before we go any further, you might be muttering to yourself, wait, is the Punisher skull symbol a meme? It has no impact font, it doesn't tell a story in multiple panels. But it does have the other essential meme ingredients. Defined by our chorus of meme experts. It is this idea that is shared by people and it is modified and it evolves like a gene.
与暴力联系在一起。我们是宝贝，伙计！你到底去哪儿了？把它扔给你们所有人！我知道你在做什么！叫我阿莫里·塞弗森。叫我本·布洛克·约翰逊。来自WBUR播客宇宙，我们为你带来《无尽线索》。在我们继续之前，你可能在嘀咕，等等，惩罚者的骷髅标志是模因吗？它没有冲击字体（impact font），它不在多个分镜中讲述故事。但它确实具备了其他基本的模因要素。正如我们的模因专家合唱团所定义的那样。它是一种被人们分享并被修改、像基因一样进化的思想。
There are really ways in which we structure and then create a shorthand for a whole set of ideas. I think at the heart of any meme, it all ladders back up to a larger kind of macro thing going on in culture. Like other memes, the Punisher skull is getting remixed all the time. With a lot of the memes we've explored in the series so far, that happens serendipitously. But the Punisher skull feels different. It hasn't just been tweaked or repurposed. According to its creator, its meaning has been turned upside down, and as a symbol, it might be in a major period of transition into something much more sinister. Today, we're looking at how the Punisher's symbol has become estranged from the Punisher's origin story,
确实有一些方式让我们构建并为一整套思想创造速记。我认为在任何模因的核心，它都回溯到文化中正在发生的某种更大的宏观事物。像其他模因一样，惩罚者的骷髅一直在被混剪。在我们目前探索的系列节目中的许多模因中，这种情况是偶然发生的。但惩罚者的骷髅感觉不同。它不仅仅是被微调或重新利用。据其创造者所说，它的含义已经被颠倒了，作为一个符号，它可能正处于一个向更险恶事物转变的主要时期。今天，我们正在研究惩罚者的标志是如何与其起源故事变得疏远的，
which, for most memes, is normal, but in this case, it's controversial, and at the heart of a battle, Punisher Style, to reclaim what the symbol means. Emory, there were basically three places I spent all of my time during middle school because I was extremely cool. Mmm. The record store, which is cool. That is cool. The candy store, which is cool. That is cool. The candy store, which my dentist would say is not cool,
对于大多数模因来说，这是正常的，但在这种情况下，它是充满争议的，并且处于一场“惩罚者风格”的战斗中心，旨在夺回该标志的含义。阿莫里，我在中学时基本上有三个地方是我待的时间最长的，因为我非常酷。嗯。唱片店，这很酷。那确实很酷。糖果店，这很酷。那确实很酷。糖果店，我的牙医会说那不酷，
and the comic book shop. With you on the first two. So I'm not a full comic book nerd, but I do remember the Punisher from the 90s. The 90s era of the Punisher. Okay. What do you remember? He was super rough looking. He was like unshaven, super hairy.
还有漫画书店。前两个我同意。所以我不是一个彻头彻尾的漫画书呆子，但我确实记得90年代的惩罚者。90年代的惩罚者时代。好的。你记得什么？他看起来超级粗犷。他没刮胡子，毛发旺盛。
If his body was architecture, it would be from the brutalist school, you know, sort of like chunked out of rough-hune slabs. Plus, he always was surrounded by this like spiral of shells flying out of his guns, out of his oozees or whatever, you know, and mostly what I remember was that huge white skull logo because it was badass as most skulls are. And Jerry Conway would agree, when he was first dreaming up the Punisher, he was inspired by an early comic book called The Phantom, featuring a warrior against evil
如果他的身体是建筑，那它会属于粗野主义流派，你知道，就像是从粗糙的石板上凿出来的一样。另外，他总是被那种从枪里、从乌兹冲锋枪或其他什么东西里飞出来的弹壳螺旋所包围，你知道，我记得最清楚的是那个巨大的白色骷髅标志，因为它像大多数骷髅一样很酷。杰瑞·康威也会同意，当他最初构思惩罚者时，他的灵感来自于一本早期的漫画书《魅影》（The Phantom），讲述了一位对抗邪恶的战士，
who wore a skull-shaped ring. And his base of operations was the skull cave. So I always thought this was enormously cool. And that, along with the idea of pirates, with the skull and crossbones of the pirates, was something I thought it would make for, kind of an interesting design for a guy who was an assassin working against the mob. That was the impulse for the skull, going back to the phantom and to the Jolly Roger.
他戴着一枚骷髅形状的戒指。他的行动基地是骷髅洞。所以我一直认为这非常酷。再加上关于海盗的想法，海盗的骷髅交叉骨，我认为这对于一个对抗黑帮的刺客来说，会是一个相当有趣的设计。这就是骷髅的冲动，回溯到《魅影》和海盗旗。
The Jolly Roger was, of course, that black flag with the white human skull and diagonally crossed bones, identifying a pirate ship that was about to attack. In the end, the Punisher kept this scary skull, lost the crossbones. But there's more to the genesis of this crazy popular skull motif than just swash-buckling rogue pirates inciting terror on the high seas, according to Nate Powell. I'm a cartoonist and graphic novelist, and I live in Bloomington, Indiana. Nate is the first cartoonist ever to win a national book award,
海盗旗当然是那面带有白色人类骷髅和对角交叉骨的黑旗，标志着一艘即将发动攻击的海盗船。最终，惩罚者保留了这个可怕的骷髅，去掉了交叉骨。但据内特·鲍威尔（Nate Powell）说，这个疯狂流行的骷髅图案的起源不仅仅是那些在公海上煽动恐怖的剑客海盗。我是一名漫画家和图像小说家，我住在印第安纳州的布卢明顿。内特是第一位获得国家图书奖的漫画家，
for his trilogy about the life of civil rights leader John Lewis. And while Nate might live in Bloomington, he'll always be from Little Rock, Arkansas. And a punk. Yes, definitely punk going on 30 years. That is one of the many punk and metal bands Nate has played in. So he not only comes from subcultures teaming with skull iconography and a military family, he was also a Marvel kid back in the 80s and 90s. But Nate says he didn't get interested
凭借他关于民权领袖约翰·刘易斯（John Lewis）生平的三部曲。虽然内特可能住在布卢明顿，但他永远来自阿肯色州的小石城。而且是个朋克。是的，绝对是朋克，快30年了。那是内特演奏过的众多朋克和金属乐队之一。所以他不仅来自充满骷髅肖像和军人家庭的亚文化，他还是80年代和90年代的漫威小孩。但内特说他并没有对
in the Punisher specifically until a few decades later. Fast forward to 2016, he's living in Southern Indiana. Going about my business, taking my kids to and from school. When he starts noticing this pronounced shift towards a hyper-masculine look, we're talking big beards, blacked out trucks, gun decals, and over and over, that menacing long in the tooth skull image. It was obvious to me that the Punisher skull was central along with black and white
惩罚者产生兴趣，直到几十年后。快进到2016年，他住在印第安纳州南部。忙着我的事，接送孩子上下学。当他开始注意到这种向超男性化外观的明显转变时，我们说的是大胡子、全黑的卡车、枪支贴花，以及一遍又一遍，那个威胁性的、长牙的骷髅形象。对我来说很明显，惩罚者的骷髅是核心，连同黑白
American flags, etc. was central to the normalization of this paramilitary aesthetic. For Nate, seeing the Punisher symbol in this paramilitary aesthetic. For Nate, seeing the Punisher symbol in this context was jarring. So he starts researching the saga of the Punisher skull icon and turning it into a comics essay, beginning with the roots of the skull and crossbones or death's head imagery. Naturally. I was expecting to land on pirates. I was not expecting to land on a proto-paramilitary unit.
美国国旗等，是这种准军事美学正常化的核心。对于内特来说，在这种背景下看到惩罚者的标志是令人震惊的。所以他开始研究惩罚者骷髅图标的传奇，并将其变成一篇漫画论文，从骷髅交叉骨或死亡之头意象的根源开始。自然地。我以为会落到海盗身上。我没想到会落到一个准军事单位原型上。
As in privateers, and this is a really important distinction. We think of pirates as Jolly, Parrot-Levin, Treasure Horton, Rum-Guzzle, and Scallywags with no real power behind them, right? But privateers are different. From the 16th to the 18th centuries, privateers are given the nod and the financial backing of colonial governments. To seize and plunder enemy ships, says Nate, without following the usual rules of war. Not being outside of the law simply being above the law.
就像私掠船一样，这是一个非常重要的区别。我们认为海盗是快乐的、鹦鹉利文（Parrot-Levin）、宝藏霍顿（Treasure Horton）、朗姆酒狂饮者和没有真正权力的无赖，对吧？但私掠船不同。从16世纪到18世纪，私掠船得到了殖民政府的点头和财政支持。内特说，去夺取和掠夺敌船，而不遵循通常的战争规则。不是在法律之外，仅仅是在法律之上。
Bottom line, he discovered that the skull has always been a symbol of power beyond good and evil. But first and foremost, a declaration of power itself. Gun 3 Filming Ainsome E50 K-9! In the 20th century, the Nazis adopted the death set head or Totenkopf. The Nazi death's head is a specific design, and it's one that you can identify on pickup trucks here in America today. The skull was also used by US troops throughout World War II, but especially in Vietnam. I love the smell of the hay pump in the morning. In the early 70s, we had a number of national traumas.
底线是，他发现骷髅一直是一个超越善恶的权力象征。但首先，它是权力本身的宣言。20世纪，纳粹采用了死亡之头（Totenkopf）。纳粹的死亡之头是一种特定的设计，你今天在美国的皮卡车上就能认出来。骷髅也被美国军队在整个二战期间使用，尤其是在越南。我喜欢早晨凝固汽油弹的味道。在70年代初，我们经历了一系列国家创伤。
To a young Jerry Conway, whose career was just getting off the ground at the time, the biggest of all was the US military's involvement in the Vietnam War. And for many people of my generation, that was a fundamental social crime that we felt that the government was perpetuating, which by itself sort of undermined your sense of the government as a force for good. So, in the pages of the Amazing Spider-Man, Jerry responded with Frank Castle, an ex-Sniper
对于年轻的杰瑞·康威来说，当时他的事业才刚刚起步，最大的创伤是美国军队卷入越南战争。对于我们这一代人中的许多人来说，那是一场根本性的社会犯罪，我们觉得政府在助长这种犯罪，这本身就削弱了你对政府作为一种向善力量的感觉。所以，在《神奇蜘蛛侠》的页面中，杰瑞用弗兰克·卡索做出了回应，一个前狙击手
turned skull sporting vigilante killing machine. It sounds like it came from frustrations with the government's use of violence. Oh, yeah, yeah. I mean, it felt like the government is taking on the wrong people and ignoring the people who are really dangerous. The Punisher was controversial from the get go.
变成了戴着骷髅的义务警员杀人机器。听起来像是源于对政府使用暴力的挫败感。哦，是的，是的。我的意思是，感觉政府在针对错误的人，而忽视了那些真正危险的人。惩罚者从一开始就充满争议。
But like any good comic book character and meme, once he shot out of Jerry's pen from the get go, but like any good comic book character and meme, once he shot out of Jerry's pen into the Marvel Universe, he kept evolving and gaining fans, lots of fans. For a period in the 80s, the Punisher was became Marvel's most popular character next Spider-Man. Maybe Jerry says because during the Reagan years, the Punisher embodied this ultimate truth, this notion that one man could wage war against crime itself. Government is not the solution to our problem.
但像任何好的漫画角色和模因一样，一旦他从杰瑞的笔下射出，进入漫威宇宙，他就不断进化并获得粉丝，大量的粉丝。在80年代的一段时间里，惩罚者成为了漫威仅次于蜘蛛侠的最受欢迎的角色。也许杰瑞说，因为在里根时代，惩罚者体现了这种终极真理，即一个人可以对犯罪本身发动战争。政府不是我们问题的解决方案。
Government is the problem. It's like a black and white character in a black and white era? Exactly. And I think that I've often said that the Punisher represents kind of a Rorschach test for the era that he's that readers discover him in. For me, in the early 70s, he was, you know, a response to a dysfunctional era in American history. In the 80s he's a triumphant character representing, you know, a black and white view of the world. And in the 2000s he's the dysfunctional
政府就是问题所在。这就像一个黑白时代的黑白角色？正是如此。而且我认为我经常说，惩罚者代表了读者发现他所处时代的一种罗夏测试（Rorschach test）。对我来说，在70年代初，他是对美国历史上一个功能失调时代的反应。在80年代，他是一个胜利的角色，代表了一种黑白分明的世界观。而在2000年代，他是功能失调的
Punisher, the despairing tragic hero who is really an outcast and no longer represents anything except his own it. Over the last few decades, there have been Punisher Spinoffs, books, films, and TV series, all adapted and written by other people that have increased its visibility. And it must be said, some of these mutations were great, and some were decidedly not great. One of the offsuits, the Punisher Armory, reads kind of like a gun catalog, and some of the movies are just so, so bad. Jerry refuses to see these movies, but all in all, while it was hard watching his blood-thirsty baby grow up, he was proud
惩罚者，那个绝望的悲剧英雄，他实际上是一个被放逐者，不再代表任何东西，除了他自己。在过去的几十年里，出现了惩罚者的衍生作品、书籍、电影和电视剧，所有这些都是由其他人改编和编写的，增加了它的知名度。必须说，其中一些变异很棒，而有些则绝对不怎么样。其中一个分支，《惩罚者军械库》（Punisher Armory），读起来像是一本枪支目录，而有些电影简直太糟糕了。杰瑞拒绝看这些电影，但总而言之，虽然看着他嗜血的“孩子”长大很艰难，但他为他们感到骄傲。
of them. Didn't feel too attached. And it's actually part of the value of the comics, is that you can reinterpret these characters, as long as you maintain some truth to the original arch type that they represent, you can reinterpret them for the time in which you're creating. About 15 years ago though, something very different started to happen. Not to the Punisher as a character, but to his symbol. It leapt off the page and took a hard right turn, not in storylines, but seriously, IRL. In large part because of US Navy SEAL, Chris Kyle.
没有感到太依恋。这实际上是漫画价值的一部分，你可以重新诠释这些角色，只要你保持对他们所代表的原始原型的某种真实性，你就可以为创作他们的时代重新诠释他们。然而，大约15年前，一些非常不同的事情开始发生。不是对惩罚者这个角色，而是对他的标志。它跳出了页面，并向右急转，不是在故事情节中，而是严肃地说，在现实生活中。很大程度上是因为美国海豹突击队队员克里斯·凯尔（Chris Kyle）。
Kyle served four tours in Iraq and was arguably the deadliest sniper in US history. He credits himself with over 160 kills. Chris Kyle also worshipped the Punisher. His unit actually called themselves the Punisher's and put the skull insignia everywhere. In his best-selling memoir, Kyle writes, quote, We spray painted it on every building or wall we could. We wanted people to know, we're here and we want to f*** with you. You know, I didn't think it was the best thing in the world, but I could kind of see it because the Punisher was a vet, you know, and was a sharpshooter in Vietnam. And in his updated version was a rock war vet. So you know it made
凯尔在伊拉克服役了四次，可以说是美国历史上最致命的狙击手。他自称有超过160次击杀。克里斯·凯尔也崇拜惩罚者。他的部队实际上称自己为“惩罚者”，并到处贴上骷髅徽章。在他的畅销回忆录中，凯尔写道，引用：“我们把它喷涂在我们可以喷涂的每一栋建筑或墙壁上。我们想让人们知道，我们在这里，我们想搞死你们。”你知道，我不认为这是世界上最好的事情，但我能理解，因为惩罚者是一名老兵，你知道，是越南的特等射手。而在他的更新版本中是一名伊拉克战争老兵。所以你知道，这对我来说
sense to me that somebody working in that world you know being a soldier might embrace that. While creator Jerry had imagined Frank Castle's story as a complicated cautionary tale. To soldiers like Chris Kyle, Frank wasn't an anti-hero. He was a hero. The Punisher School became sort of an icon for some members of the US military, Iraqi security forces, even Shiite militias in the fight against ISIS. Then, punk Punisher historian Nate Powell says it made another leap, moving from the US military
说得通，在这个世界里工作的人，你知道，作为一名士兵，可能会拥抱这一点。虽然创造者杰瑞把弗兰克·卡索的故事想象成一个复杂的警示故事。对于像克里斯·凯尔这样的士兵来说，弗兰克不是反英雄。他是一个英雄。惩罚者骷髅成为了美国军队、伊拉克安全部队，甚至在打击ISIS的战斗中什叶派民兵的一些成员的偶像。然后，朋克惩罚者历史学家内特·鲍威尔说它又实现了一次飞跃，从美国军队
into American law enforcement. As a very clear direct response to the movement for Black Lives throughout the United States. Around 2014, right as tensions between police and communities of color were reaching a boiling point. That notorious long-thanged skull started showing up up on blue lives matter, paraphernalia. Police challenge coins, officers uniforms, patrol cars, sending a message according to one Kentucky police chief that they would take any means necessary to keep their community safe. Which feels like coded language.
进入了美国执法部门。作为对全美“黑人的命也是命”（Black Lives Matter）运动的一个非常明确的直接回应。大约在2014年，就在警察与有色人种社区之间的紧张关系达到沸点时。那个臭名昭著的长牙骷髅开始出现在“蓝命也是命”（Blue Lives Matter）的装备上。警察挑战币、警官制服、巡逻车，传达了一个信息，据一位肯塔基州警察局长称，他们将采取任何必要手段来确保社区安全。这感觉像是编码语言。
In this time, creator Jerry Conway could not empathize. By definition, he's the opposite of what they're supposed to be. You know, he is someone who is outside the law, taking the law into his own hands. So if they're claiming the Punisher as their symbol, they are saying they are outlaws, and that they are saying they are outlaws, and they are criminals, and that they are enemies of society. It's that really what they want to be saying.
在这个时代，创造者杰瑞·康威无法产生共鸣。根据定义，他是他们应该成为的反面。你知道，他是一个在法律之外，亲自采取行动的人。所以如果他们声称惩罚者是他们的标志，他们就是在说他们是亡命之徒，他们是罪犯，他们是社会的敌人。这真的是他们想表达的意思吗？
Enemies of the state within the state. Yes. Yeah. I mean, it's such a fundamental misreading of the character that that appalls me. But the appropriation or misappropriation, if you ask Jerry, of the Punisher School symbol, didn't stop there. In recent years, it's also become the darling of some on the right, like Fox News commentator Sean Hannity. His predecessor, President Trump, in less than two years now, is given power back to you.
国家内部的国家敌人。是的。是的。我的意思是，这是对角色的根本性误读，这让我感到震惊。但如果你问杰瑞，惩罚者骷髅标志的挪用或滥用并没有就此停止。近年来，它也成为了右翼一些人的宠儿，比如福克斯新闻评论员肖恩·汉尼提（Sean Hannity）。他的前任，特朗普总统，在不到两年的时间里，把权力还给了你。
In factions of the far right, who, for whatever reasons, feel that government, modern society, etc., have failed them, or left them behind, or broken some kind of promise, which is not unlike the actions of the Punisher himself, an attempt to achieve justice through direct action, taking on the, quote, forces of evil by any means necessary. A variation of the Punisher logo turned up on some white supremacists marching in the 2017
在极右翼的派系中，无论出于什么原因，他们觉得政府、现代社会等辜负了他们，或者抛弃了他们，或者违背了某种承诺，这与惩罚者本人的行为没有什么不同，试图通过直接行动实现正义，不惜一切代价对抗所谓的“邪恶势力”。惩罚者标志的一个变体出现在一些白人至上主义者身上，他们在2017年
unite the right rally in Charlottesville. And it's invoked with the anti-government militia movement, the three percenters. Here's a guy we talked to at a, quote, freedom rally in Boston this fall, who is waving a massive Punisher flag. It's a 3% skull, okay? And 3% of the people originally fought the British. Only 3% of the people.
夏洛茨维尔的“团结右翼”（Unite the Right）集会上游行。它被反政府民兵运动“百分之三”（Three Percenters）所援引。这是我们今年秋天在波士顿的一次所谓的“自由集会”上采访的一个人，他挥舞着一面巨大的惩罚者旗帜。这是一个3%的骷髅，好吗？最初只有3%的人与英国人作战。只有3%的人。
I am part of that 3% that is not afraid of the government. And most recently, it appeared among some of the armed insurrectionists that violently stormed the US Capitol on January 6th. They're going to use this against us as far as they can. The land playing nice, no f**king more. Obviously, there is a huge difference between state-backed police and military forces and paramilitary extremist groups. Except, in a world where off-duty police officers
我是那3%不害怕政府的人的一部分。最近，它出现在一些暴力冲击美国国会大厦的武装叛乱分子中，在1月6日。他们会尽可能地利用这一点来对付我们。不再玩好人了，去他妈的。显然，国家支持的警察和军队与准军事极端组织之间存在巨大差异。除了，在一个下班警察
are among the January 6th writers where military personnel eventually find work at Blackwater and other private security firms, whereas the rage against the machine song says, so for those that work forces, draw the same number that broad crosses. Those lines seem to be getting even more blurry. So Nate argues that no matter who is flaunting the Punisher emblem, the skull is functioning
是1月6日暴徒之一的世界里，军事人员最终在黑水公司（Blackwater）和其他私人保安公司找到工作，正如“暴力反抗机器”（Rage Against the Machine）的歌词所说，所以对于那些为部队工作的人，画出同样的数字，宽十字架。这些界限似乎变得越来越模糊。所以内特认为，无论谁在炫耀惩罚者徽章，骷髅都在
once again as a symbol of power beyond the law. We've basically gone full circle. This logo has broken free from the gravitational field of the Marvel Universe, and any inciting influences on the character or its context. The comic book symbol itself reached escape velocity, but now we are back to its original intent. The seizure of this specific skull logo, especially by American police or some on the extreme and far right, really pissed off the guy who brought him to life in Marvel Comics almost 50 years ago. Last summer, after photos of police officers wearing Punisher skull patches, while cracking
再次作为一种超越法律的权力象征发挥作用。我们基本上绕了一圈。这个标志已经从漫威宇宙的引力场中挣脱出来，以及对该角色或其背景的任何煽动性影响。漫画书标志本身达到了逃逸速度，但现在我们回到了它的最初意图。这个特定骷髅标志的夺取，特别是被美国警察或极右翼的一些人夺取，真的激怒了近50年前在漫威漫画中赋予他生命的那个人。去年夏天，在警官佩戴惩罚者骷髅补丁的照片，同时镇压
down on Black Lives Matter protesters went viral, Jerry took matters into his own hands. Not quite Punisher style. What did he do and did it work? We'll find out after the break. You're listening to endless thread on 99% invisible. Five, four, five, nine, four, five, nine, four, five, nine.
“黑人的命也是命”抗议者时疯传，杰瑞亲自采取了行动。不太像惩罚者风格。他做了什么，成功了吗？休息后我们再揭晓。你正在收听《99%无形》的《无尽线索》。五，四，五，九，四，五，九，四，五，九。
In June of 2020, racial justice protests were spreading across the country. And I wanted to be part of that. And also, I was in the middle of the pandemic, like everybody else, and going stork-razy. So the Punisher's daddy, Jerry Comway, launched the first ever BLM skulls for justice campaign. His intentions were twofold. One, support the Black Lives Matter movement by raising money for the Los Angeles chapter, and two, reclaim the skull.
2020年6月，种族正义抗议活动在全国蔓延。我想参与其中。而且，我和其他人一样，正处于大流行之中，快疯了。所以惩罚者的“爸爸”，杰瑞·康威，发起了有史以来第一次“为正义的BLM骷髅”运动。他的意图是双重的。第一，通过为洛杉矶分会筹款来支持“黑人的命也是命”运动，第二，夺回骷髅。
Potentially, as a symbol for justice, rather than for oppression, that while the Punisher was a very problematic hero, he was trying to fight on the side of right. Jerry invited young artists of color to come up with a new iteration of the Punisher Skull emblem, one that would challenge its affiliation with, quote, lawless police oppression, fight fire with fire, logo versus logo. And lots of artists answered this call.
潜在地，作为一个正义的象征，而不是压迫的象征，虽然惩罚者是一个非常有问题的英雄，但他试图站在正义的一边。杰瑞邀请年轻的有色人种艺术家提出惩罚者骷髅标志的新迭代，一个将挑战其与所谓的“无法无天的警察压迫”的联系，以牙还牙，标志对标志。许多艺术家响应了这一号召。
The top-selling logo designed by an LA-based Vietnamese indie comics artist transformed this goal into a black power fist. The teeth, the fingers gripping the letters, BLM. A blood-red tear drips from one eye. And by one metric, the campaign was a smash success, raising over $75,000 for the Black Lives Matter Los Angeles chapter. far more than Jerry ever imagined. As for Jerry's more abstract goal of reclaiming the skull for justice? I mean, I've heard one or two people on Twitter saying that there's literally no way that the Punisher logo
由一位洛杉矶越南裔独立漫画艺术家设计的畅销标志将这个目标转化为一个黑人权力拳头。牙齿，手指抓着字母，BLM。一颗血红色的眼泪从一只眼睛滴下。从一个指标来看，这场运动取得了巨大的成功，为“黑人的命也是命”洛杉矶分会筹集了超过75,000美元。远超杰瑞的想象。至于杰瑞夺回骷髅以实现正义的更抽象的目标？我的意思是，我听到推特上有一两个人说，惩罚者标志
can ever be anything except a symbol of oppression. And I think that's just, you know, no, come on. But even if that were the case, sticking your finger in the eye of the bad guys is always a good deal. You know, and putting out sweatshirts that had the BLM logo with the Punisher logo is a, you know, it's a pretty hefty FU to people who deserve to have an FU.
除了作为压迫的象征外，根本不可能成为其他任何东西。我认为那只是，你知道，不，得了吧。但即使是那样，戳瞎坏人的眼睛总是一笔好买卖。你知道，推出带有BLM标志和惩罚者标志的运动衫，你知道，这对那些值得被“去他妈的”的人来说是一个相当沉重的“去他妈的”。
Jerry says he launched the logo campaign independently, because the symbol was already controversial. Also, this was when Black Lives Matter protesters were grappling with how white participants could be allies without appropriating the megaphone or the spotlight. So would Jerry's effort feel off? We had to get at least one perspective from the BLM ranks and we did. But let's get one thing straight first. I am not a fan of superhero comics.
杰瑞说他独立发起了标志运动，因为这个标志已经充满争议。此外，当时“黑人的命也是命”抗议者正在努力解决白人参与者如何在不挪用扩音器或聚光灯的情况下成为盟友。那么杰瑞的努力会感觉不对劲吗？我们必须从BLM队伍中获得至少一个视角，我们做到了。但首先让我们明确一件事。我不是超级英雄漫画的粉丝。
I love anti-heroes. Dr. Kimberly McNair is very familiar with the Punisher Canon and... I am a member of Black Lives Matter Los Angeles. And I am also a post-doctoral fellow at Stanford University in African and African American studies. She actually studies t-shirt culture and black activist traditions.
我喜欢反英雄。金伯利·麦克奈尔（Kimberly McNair）博士非常熟悉惩罚者正典，而且……我是“黑人的命也是命”洛杉矶分会的成员。我还是斯坦福大学非洲和非裔美国人研究的博士后研究员。她实际上研究T恤文化和黑人活动家传统。
And Kim says she understands Jerry Conway's intention to protect his creative legacy. Set the record straight, as far as BLMLA is concerned. Why supremacists are using this image to intimidate black people. And no matter who a person is, and where they are, trying to up in that effort is something that I believe is commendable, and something that BLMLA believes is absolutely necessary. But overall, we always try to coordinate efforts with parties. That makes an even larger impact.
金说她理解杰瑞·康威保护其创作遗产的意图。就BLMLA而言，澄清事实。白人至上主义者正在使用这个形象来恐吓黑人。无论一个人是谁，无论他们在哪里，试图颠覆这种努力是我认为值得称赞的事情，也是BLMLA认为绝对必要的事情。但总的来说，我们总是尝试与各方协调努力。这会产生更大的影响。
And it also helps us try and steer the conversation towards not only has this happened to Mr. Conway, and this was not the original intent or purpose or meaning of the punisher and the punisher's goal, but also how can we make this conversation more about not only the military's use of the Punisher School, but the militarization of the police? Or Kim says to draw a line from that to the over-policing of black communities, to how
这也帮助我们尝试将对话引导到不仅是康威先生发生了这种情况，而且这不是惩罚者和惩罚者目标的最初意图或目的或意义，而且我们如何能让这次对话更多地不仅关于军队对惩罚者骷髅的使用，而且关于警察的军事化？或者金说，从那里划出一条线，到对黑人社区的过度警务，到如何
images of black people themselves have been co-opted or demonized in the service of white supremacy. Her point is there are so many possibilities to take the conversation about one symbol to the next level. And to me this is really a beautiful thing because it is Mr. Conway's entry way in to a movement that is about broader things. Jerry did tell us that he didn't expect that the Black Lives Matter movement would adopt the Justice-themed Punisher logo as their own. But we still wanted to ask him a bigger question that we've been puzzling over, the one that hovered above the campaign. Do you think it's even possible to sort of give a movement a logo?
黑人本身的形象在白人至上主义的服务中被挪用或妖魔化。她的观点是，有太多的可能性将关于一个标志的对话提升到一个新的水平。对我来说，这真是一件美丽的事情，因为这是康威先生进入一场关于更广泛事物的运动的切入点。杰瑞确实告诉我们，他没想到“黑人的命也是命”运动会采用以正义为主题的惩罚者标志作为他们自己的标志。但我们仍然想问他一个我们一直在困惑的更大的问题，那个悬在运动之上的问题。你认为给一场运动一个标志甚至可能吗？
There's this saying and I love the saying is by Leo Watson, she's a Mori elder and it says, if you have come here to help me you're wasting your time, but you have come because your liberation is bound up with mine, then let us work together. And so the idea of gifting a movement, imagery, or a symbol, you have to work with those people who are at the center of the movement. You have to work with those people. Don't give anything. You create it with the people. These days, the tug of war over the Punisher's skull symbol rages on.
有一句谚语，我喜欢这句谚语，是利奥·沃森（Leo Watson）说的，她是毛利长老，她说，如果你来这里是为了帮助我，你在浪费时间，但如果你来是因为你的解放与我的解放息息相关，那么让我们一起工作。所以，赠送一场运动、意象或一个标志的想法，你必须与那些处于运动中心的人一起工作。你必须与那些人一起工作。不要给予任何东西。你是与人们一起创造它。这些天，关于惩罚者骷髅标志的拉锯战仍在继续。
Over the last few months, our team has gone searching for the Punisher, IRL. And even though we've spied the toothy skull in plenty of places, it wasn't easy finding people who wanted to talk about it. We did, however, strike gold at the, quote, stand up for Freedom Rally in Boston, an event organized to oppose vaccine mandates. There, we chatted with a few dozen folks about what that skull means to them, and all we can say is, there is still not a clear consensus. Does it mean anything to you in particular?
在过去的几个月里，我们的团队一直在寻找现实生活中的惩罚者。即使我们在很多地方窥探到了那个露齿的骷髅，但要找到愿意谈论它的人并不容易。然而，我们在波士顿的所谓的“为自由挺身而出”（Stand up for Freedom）集会上确实挖到了金矿，这是一个为反对疫苗强制令而组织的活动。在那里，我们与几十个人聊了聊那个骷髅对他们意味着什么，我们只能说，仍然没有明确的共识。它对你有什么特别的意义吗？
Yeah, Frank Cas is a badass. Yeah, that's true, really.. I mean skulls have always been a power symbol throughout the world you know. It's just a power symbol more than anything. I ride a black Harley Davidson fat boy with 18s on it. It's right there and it has two American flags on the bars and it looks awesome and I feel like the partnership when I'm coming through. You know an American Patriot supporting that country. Yeah that's a cool skull. Yeah I've seen it around. I don't like when the thin blue lines put over it though because that's the boot liquor flag and when you put the Punisher skull over the boot liquor flag and the comics he killed police. Marines, I know quite a few Marines that do have it. Yeah, and they do enjoy it.
是的，弗兰克·卡索是个硬汉。是的，那是真的，真的……我的意思是，骷髅在世界各地一直是一个权力象征，你知道。它不仅仅是一个权力象征。我骑着一辆带有18英寸把手的黑色哈雷戴维森胖男孩（Fat Boy）。它就在那里，把手上插着两面美国国旗，看起来棒极了，当我经过时，我觉得自己像个惩罚者。你知道，一个支持那个国家的美国爱国者。是的，那是个很酷的骷髅。是的，我见过它。我不喜欢细蓝线把它覆盖在上面，因为那是“舔靴者”（boot liquor）旗帜，当你把惩罚者骷髅放在舔靴者旗帜上时，在漫画里他杀了警察。海军陆战队，我知道不少海军陆战队员确实有它。是的，他们确实很喜欢它。
And I think they stand for what, you know, we all stand for the USA right here with their else Chann. Why do you think that skull is a symbol of that? Pain and punishment for justice, you know, doing what's right for the people. Skull, I didn't know what it meant before. Any time I saw it, I would assume the punish shirt. But now, because I've been to so many rallies and I've seen that on hats and shirts of people that are not very nice, I'm going to go out and then a limb and assume it represents a hate group or an hate ideology or something along that line.
我认为他们代表了，你知道，我们所有人都代表美国，就在这里，还有其他什么。你为什么认为那个骷髅是那个的象征？为了正义的痛苦和惩罚，你知道，为人民做正确的事。骷髅，我以前不知道它意味着什么。每当我看到它，我就会假设是惩罚者。但现在，因为我参加过很多集会，我在那些不太好的人的帽子和衬衫上看到过它，我要冒险假设它代表一个仇恨团体或一种仇恨意识形态或类似的东西。
And the fact that in 2021, there's still more symbols that are coming up that we don't know of. It's just like wild to me. We also talked to a comic book store owner up in Maine and he just wasn't sure. I'll be honest when I see it, I kind of, you know, my hairs go up a little bit, it's like because I don't know what the intention is behind it. It's those last comments about the confusion, the not knowing that really stuck with us. Because with some symbols, it's really clear what they mean,
而且事实上，在2021年，仍然有更多的符号出现，我们不知道。这对我来说太疯狂了。我们还和缅因州的一位漫画书店老板谈过，他只是不确定。老实说，当我看到它时，我有点，你知道，我的汗毛竖起来了，因为我不知道它背后的意图是什么。正是那些关于困惑、不知道的最后评论真正困扰着我们。因为对于一些符号，它们的含义非常明确，
no matter the context. Take the swastika, originally an ancient good luck symbol. It has been forever corrupted by Nazi propaganda. The Confederate flag, pretty hard to defend as just a symbol of southern heritage and pride. Or Pepe the Frog, the sad cartoon amphibian, he's been used as the alt-rights internet bigot. These are just a few of the 200-plus entries
无论背景如何。以纳粹万字旗为例，最初是一个古老的幸运符号。它已经被纳粹宣传永远腐蚀了。邦联旗，很难仅仅将其辩护为南方遗产和自豪感的象征。或者佩佩蛙（Pepe the Frog），那个悲伤的卡通两栖动物，他被用作另类右翼的互联网偏执狂。这些只是200多个条目中的几个
in the anti-definition leagues hate to symbol database. The Punisher School is not currently one of them. Sometimes it really is just a representation of the Marvel character. But more and more, it's an image that seems to denote a distrust of authority and trust in the ultimate authority of violence. It still has a foot in both worlds for now. What makes all of this extra confusing is that it's everywhere.
在反诽谤联盟的仇恨符号数据库中。惩罚者骷髅目前不是其中之一。有时它确实只是漫威角色的代表。但越来越多地，它似乎是一个表示对权威的不信任和对暴力终极权威的信任的形象。它目前在两个世界中都有一只脚。让这一切更加令人困惑的是，它无处不在。
Go inside your local Walmart or Army surplus store and you can find anything from Punisher pajama pants to tactical vests. Online you can order skull shirts and hats galore, flags, decals, stickers for your gun mag, pop sockets. There's just so much... Cool stuff for people to buy. In Punisher expert Nate Powell's mind, that's the real danger. The symbol is so deeply embedded in pop culture, it can be hard to pin down its meaning. Is a person wearing it only because they're a diehard Marvel fan, or as a dog whistle of white supremacy?
走进你当地的沃尔玛或军队剩余物资商店，你可以找到从惩罚者睡裤到战术背心的任何东西。在线你可以订购大量的骷髅衬衫和帽子、旗帜、贴花、枪支弹药贴纸、手机气囊支架。有太多的……人们可以买的酷东西。在惩罚者专家内特·鲍威尔看来，那才是真正的危险。这个符号深深植根于流行文化中，很难确定它的含义。一个人戴着它仅仅是因为他们是漫威的铁杆粉丝，还是作为白人至上主义的狗哨？
Maybe as a signal of anti-government sentiment, something in between? Does it become a gateway or a cover for those ideologies and political views the more ubiquitous it gets? It's a really good case study in seeing how the symbol evolves, in seeing how it gains power by appearing to lose political specificity. And by normalizing fascist and paramilitary activity, it allows space for all that stuff to expand and continue. What then should be done, and who should be doing it? Should the burden to wrangle a symbol gun while be shouldered by its creator alone? Is there any other entity that might have a dog in this fight?
也许作为反政府情绪的信号，介于两者之间？它变得越普遍，它是否就越成为那些意识形态和政治观点的门户或掩护？这是一个很好的案例研究，可以看到符号是如何进化的，可以看到它如何通过看起来失去政治特殊性而获得权力。通过使法西斯和准军事活动正常化，它为所有这些东西的扩张和持续提供了空间。那么应该做什么，谁应该做？驯服一个符号的负担应该由其创造者独自承担吗？还有其他实体可能在这场斗争中有利害关系吗？
If you ask BLMLA member Dr. Kimberly McNair. I think Marvel should sue. I want to imagine a world beyond punitive justice, but I'm thinking about accountability. I'm thinking about ways to redress harm that has been done by those who have profited they've made money. Oh right, unlike, say Pepe the Frog, who belongs to one independent artist named Matt Fury, the Punisher is the intellectual property of Marvel Comics, which is a subsidiary of... The Walt Disney Company, one of the world's largest and most litigious media and entertainment conglomerates, one that takes copyright and trademark infringement quite seriously.
如果你问BLMLA成员金伯利·麦克奈尔博士。我认为漫威应该起诉。我想想象一个超越惩罚性正义的世界，但我正在考虑问责制。我正在考虑通过那些获利的人——他们赚了钱——来纠正已经造成的伤害的方法。哦，对了，不像，比如说佩佩蛙，它属于一个名叫马特·弗里（Matt Fury）的独立艺术家，惩罚者是漫威漫画的知识产权，它是……华特迪士尼公司的子公司，世界上最大、最爱打官司的媒体和娱乐集团之一，一个非常认真对待版权和商标侵权的公司。
Disney has been known to go after just about anyone using unauthorized mouse years, daycares, DJ dead mouse, etc. And when it comes to unauthorized use of the Punisher skull, there have been repeated calls by fans on social media for Marvel slash Disney to do something. When we contacted reps from Marvel and Disney to find out where they are in this whole wrestling match, we got. But there's been a lot of dog and reporting on this issue in comic book trade publications. And from what we can tell, because of some murky trade mark territory, Marvel probably has limited legal recourse to stop the spread of the Punisher
迪士尼以起诉任何未经授权使用米老鼠形象的人而闻名，无论是托儿所、DJ Deadmau5等等。当涉及到未经授权使用惩罚者骷髅标志时，社交媒体上的粉丝们一再呼吁漫威或迪士尼采取行动。当我们联系漫威和迪士尼的代表，想了解他们在这场拉锯战中的立场时，我们得到了回应。但在漫画行业的贸易出版物中，关于这个问题的报道非常多。据我们所知，由于商标领域的一些模糊地带，漫威在阻止惩罚者标志传播方面的法律手段可能非常有限。
School, especially when it comes to non-commercial use. Police officers wearing Punisher patches at BLM protests, for example. But commercial use is not a trademark gray area, and it's really easy to get your hands on some bootleg Punisher merch. Jerry's best guess as to why Marvel hasn't cracked down on these unlicensed distributors? The promoters of these are all fly by night, you know, Etsy kind of companies. And it would be like whack a mole. So far, the company has come out and publicly denounced racism. And when pressed on the appropriation of the skull, a Marvel spokesperson told Gismoto their stance is laid out in a 2019 Punisher comic. In that issue, Frank Castle encounters two NYPD officers displaying the skull decal, tears it off,
特别是在非商业用途方面。例如，警察在BLM抗议活动中佩戴惩罚者徽章。但商业用途并非商标灰色地带，而且很容易买到盗版惩罚者周边商品。杰瑞对于漫威为何没有打击这些无证经销商的最佳猜测是：这些推广者都是昙花一现的Etsy类公司。打击他们就像玩打地鼠游戏一样。到目前为止，该公司已经公开谴责了种族主义。当被问及对骷髅标志的挪用时，漫威发言人告诉Gizmodo，他们的立场已在2019年的《惩罚者》漫画中阐明。在那一期中，弗兰克·卡索遇到了两名佩戴骷髅贴纸的纽约警察，他撕下了贴纸，
and lectures them, saying, quote, you boys need a role model. His name is Captain America, and he'd be happy to have you. Which is super helpful if you actually read Punisher comics. A stronger offense from Marvel and Disney you actually read Punisher Comics. A stronger offense from Marvel and Disney might actually put an end to the power struggle over this memafide logo, right? Hmm, hard-telling not knowing.
并教训他们说：“你们这些小伙子需要一个榜样。他的名字叫美国队长，他会很乐意接纳你们。”如果你真的读过《惩罚者》漫画，这非常有帮助。漫威和迪士尼采取更强硬的攻势，或许真的能结束这场关于这个标志性Logo的权力斗争，对吧？嗯，很难说，谁知道呢。
But if, as our Punisher authority Nate Powell likes to say, the skull symbol has in fact reached escape velocity, chances are, this meme will continue to have a life of its own. And in his view, trying to redefine the Punisher symbol or the character is a massive waste of time right now. Why can't we just continue spending that time and spending more time trying to prevent police officers from, you know, killing black citizens without accountability? officers from killing black citizens without accountability.
但正如我们惩罚者权威内特·鲍威尔所说，如果骷髅标志确实已经达到了“逃逸速度”，那么这个模因很可能会继续拥有自己的生命力。在他看来，试图重新定义惩罚者标志或角色目前是在浪费时间。为什么我们不能继续把时间花在防止警察在没有问责的情况下杀害黑人公民上呢？
Sometimes you just have to recognize that there will be no reclamation. For Jerry Conway, the debate isn't over. Whether the Punisher's symbol can ever be reclaimed as a symbol for justice remains an open question. Since the Punisher was spotted on Capitol rioters, demands on Marvel to retire the Punisher character and his logo have only gotten louder
有时你不得不承认，有些东西是无法挽回的。对于杰瑞·康威来说，争论还没有结束。惩罚者的标志是否能重新成为正义的象征，仍然是一个悬而未决的问题。自从在国会大厦骚乱者身上发现惩罚者标志以来，要求漫威让惩罚者角色及其标志退役的呼声越来越高，
from both fans and industry leaders. Instead of canceling him or killing him off, Jerry Comway says, let the Punisher go dormant for a few years. And then let's reinvent Frank Castle, give him a new mission, maybe even a new identity. You know, they'll come at time just like in the 80s when that character can be rebooted you know, and turned into something new. I mean, my personal preference would be that the next
无论是来自粉丝还是行业领袖。杰瑞·康威说，与其取消或杀死他，不如让惩罚者沉寂几年。然后让我们重塑弗兰克·卡索，给他一个新的使命，甚至一个新的身份。你知道，就像80年代一样，总有一天这个角色可以被重启，变成新的东西。我的个人偏好是，下一个
iteration of the Punisher would be a black vet, you know, who comes back and faces the issues that minorities in the world face today. Maybe then the Punisher will have something to say to the next generation. And again, as I say, like a Roshark test, and when he does, you know, I'll be proud of him again. And Liz Thread is a production of WBUR in Boston, hosted by Ben Brock Johnson in Amory Seavortson. This episode was produced by Nora Sacks as part of the series on the cultural history and importance of memes. Enlis Thred is made by producers Dean Russell, Nora Sacks, Kristen Torres, and Quincy Walters, editing by Marine McMurray, mixed sound design and original music by Matt Reed.
惩罚者的迭代将是一位黑人退伍军人，他回来后面对当今少数族裔在世界上所面临的问题。也许到那时，惩罚者会对下一代有所启示。再说一次，就像罗夏测试一样，当他做到这一点时，我会再次为他感到骄傲。《Endless Thread》是波士顿WBUR制作的节目，由本·布洛克·约翰逊和阿莫里·塞沃森主持。本集由诺拉·萨克斯制作，是关于模因文化历史和重要性系列节目的一部分。《Endless Thread》由制作人迪恩·拉塞尔、诺拉·萨克斯、克里斯汀·托雷斯和昆西·沃尔特斯制作，编辑是玛琳·麦克默里，混音和原创音乐由马特·里德负责。
The meme experts you heard were Jean Lucas Tringini, Joan Donovan, and Amanda Brennan. Enlis Thred is one of the great ones. Go subscribe now. 99% invisible is the Laney Hall, Kurt Colestead, Swansea Out, Emmett Fitzgerald, Vivian Le, Joe Rosenberg, Chris Baroube, Christopher Johnson, Lashemadon, Sophia Klatsker, Jason De Leon, and me Roman Mars. We are part of the Stitcher and Serious XM Podcast family. Now we head to our sixth block North in the Pandora Building. In beautiful.
你听到的模因专家是让·卢卡斯·特林吉尼、琼·多诺万和阿曼达·布伦南。《Endless Thread》是最好的节目之一。现在就去订阅吧。《99% Invisible》的团队包括莱尼·霍尔、库尔特·科尔斯特德、斯旺西·奥特、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、薇薇安·勒、乔·罗森伯格、克里斯·巴鲁贝、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、拉什马顿、索菲亚·克拉茨克、杰森·德·莱昂，以及我，罗曼·马斯。我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客家族的一部分。现在我们前往位于潘多拉大厦的第六街区。在美丽的
Uptown. Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at Roman Mars and the show at 99piOrk. We're on Instagram and Reddit too. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org Call me Stitcher. I'm serious. Excellent. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
加利福尼亚州奥克兰的上城区。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与讨论。你可以在推特上关注我@RomanMars和节目@99piOrg。我们在Instagram和Reddit上也有账号。你可以在99PI.org找到我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目的链接以及《99PI》的所有往期节目。叫我Stitcher。我是认真的。太棒了。本集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。